[Musique]
combien d'espèces de baleines vivent
dans l'arctique canadien trois espèces
vivent en permanence dans cette région
le narval le béluga et la baleine
boréale aussi appelés baleines du
groenland leurs prédateurs principal les
polars fréquente aussi ses eaux en été
le narval et la baleine boréale vive
strictement en arctique alors qu'une
population de bélugas bien connu se
trouve aussi dans l'estuaire du saint
laurent ces baleines ont un fort adapté
à la vie en eau froide elles sont dotées
d'une épaisse couche de gras qui sert
d'isolant et de réserves d'énergie
d'environ 10 cm chez le narval elle
atteint jusqu'à 50 cm chez la baleine
boréale elles sont aussi dépourvu de
nageoire dorsale qui chez les autres
baleines servir est à évacuer la chaleur
le narval et le béluga ont plutôt une
crête dorsale plus solide qui
permettrait de casser la glace pour
remonter à la surface ces trois espèces
de baleines sont menacés par
l'accélération des changements
climatiques car elles se servent de la
banquise pour chasser et se cacher des
prédateurs comme les polars la fonte des
glaces augmente aussi le trafic maritime
est donc le bruit et les risques de
collision leur territoire étant
difficile d'accès pour les scientifiques
ces mammifères sont peu connus davantage
de recherches sont nécessaires pour
comprendre à quel point ils sont
vulnérables aux changements provoqués
par les humains